my next guest are both texas lawmakers
who have witnessed a crisis firsthand
and urging the administration to take
action joining me now are texas
congressman tony gonzalez and august
fluger mr gonzalez you saw this
describe it for people because we can
see it with our own eyes but when you
are there you know outside of the
pictures you get the full sense of the
enormity of the problem
yeah i represent del rio and right now
in del rio it is as if a hurricane has
hit that small town you know border
patrol and other law enforcement
agencies are doing everything they
possibly can the unity that they've done
that they've posed to come together to
get through this crisis is unlike any
other the latest updated numbers i have
as of this morning are there 4 400
migrants still remaining under the
bridge but there's a there's over 2 000
migrants on the mexican side of the
border i mean the border patrol agents
are literally saving lives just last
night one of the migrants delivered a
child lit they literally delivered a
child underneath the bridge these are
the type of things that are happening
every single day throughout not only in
del rio but other sectors as well
meanwhile in el paso they they uh the el
paso agents caught two million dollars
worth of narcotics this is a problem
that is continuing to grow continuing to
spiral out of control and expelling
migrants that do not qualify for asylum
is part of that solution but mr fluger
as you heard there are many democrats
who are now demanding that the
administration reverse course you even
had the envoy just resigned saying that
it was wrong to be sending these people
who don't qualify for asylum back to
haiti your thoughts
well it's clear that it's a crisis and
president biden getting
attacks from both sides of the aisle is
because he can't get a handle on this
situation you have a democratic mayor of
del rio mr lozano who is has been crying
out for help tony gonzalez is doing a
great job my hometown is about two hours
from there and tony's doing a great job
of representing the interest in getting
the story out what i saw is is just
horrific on saturday fifteen thousand
migrants meanwhile yesterday when asking
mayorkas a very simple question is the
border more secure under your leadership
he said well it's neither more secure
nor less secure i'm sorry we have almost
1.5 million illegal immigrants as
opposed to 500 000 last year it's
incredibly
disastrous what's going on mr gonzalez
what happens when all the border patrol
has to focus on thousands of migrants
there in del rio the border is actually
quite long and we just do not have
enough resources to cover all of it
yeah there is a national security uh uh
event that that is just brewing i mean
you can see another 911 type event uh on
the on the horizon with everything that
the debacle in afghanistan coupled with
a wide open border a southern border it
just creates a an environment ripe for
disaster for americans in the big bend
sector the sector right over very remote
part of the the southern border
agent very few agents very limited
resources you know if this
administration was serious about
protecting the southern border they
would focus on technology that's a
softer one of the software three
elements that they could do to secure
the border but they have done nothing it
is as if there are that is as if the
biden administration is waiting for
another 9 11 to happen
mr fluger what do you think happens in
the next few days i mean you have the
biden administration trying to save its
legislative agenda on on economics and
changing all of that okay so they have
that bucket yeah afghanistan continues
all the americans are not out the
special immigration immigrant visas are
not out you have inflation concerns and
then you have this crisis on the border
and the only time that they actually
have had for example the one in charge
kamala harris speak to it was when she
mistakenly said that the border patrol
was whipping migrants
well it's clear that they're trying to
shift the narrative away from the real
disaster whether it's afghanistan or our
southern border our country is now less
secure because of president biden where
are the democrats who just two years ago
went to the border and cried out for
help i asked another question to
secretary myokas yesterday and that is
what is the number of known or suspected
terrorists that have entered this
country because the outgoing border
patrol chief
who left on his own free will wrote a
letter and said that it is in record
numbers the american public deserves to
know that we're not going to let this
administration shift the narrative away
from the real disaster we are less
secure because of them whether it's
afghanistan or at our southern border we
need the president and the vice
president to go there to acknowledge
that this is a problem and to defend
american interest in american citizens
maybe last question to you mr gonzalez
with the left now
agitating you've seen the president ran
as a moderate right or that's how he
said he said he was a moderate not a
part of the bernie wing bernie sanders
wing but now you have the left asking us
who do you think ends up
winning his attention
in this matter
yeah i think the loser in all of this is
the american public you know here you
have the house democrats uh finally
getting some of the house democrats
finally getting involved in this border
crisis and it's not because of the 33
abuse allegations by hhs for migrant
children uh it's not by some of the the
other chaos you're seeing but it's
racially driven you know one out of the
1.5 million migrants that have come over
many of them are brown many of them are
have a hispanic descent coming from
central and south america why was there
no outrage then the loser in all of this
is the american public
well i know that secretary marcus is not
the only one who works 18 hours a day
trying to do its uh work i know that you
two do as well we appreciate your time
this morning thank you
thank you hi everyone i'm brian kilmeade
i want you to do me a favor i want you
to click to subscribe to the fox news
youtube page this is the only way that i
know for sure that you're not going to
miss any great commentary any great news
bites any great interviews coming your
way on fox you can get it all here on
youtube so subscribe right now